Fox News and news corporation had Rupert
Murdoch has revealed in court filings
related to the Dominion lawsuit against
Fox News that Sean Hannity was privately
disgusted with Donald Trump's pushing of
the big lie that he actually won the
2020 election this Dominion lawsuit
against Fox News is ending up being just
a treasure Trove of gold in learning
what was really going on behind the
scenes at Fox and it turns out the fox
hosts didn't really believe Trump's lies
about the election that's the biggest
takeaway
we'll see where the defamation suit goes
I would love to see Rupert Murdoch have
to pay out a billion bucks over it we'll
follow it we'll see what happens